france avait en effet je vais m'asseoir
comme bakchich la colère ça les
questions à notre équipe et je suis
préoccupé parce que je te voit boire de
l'eau bah écoute et justement et tu
devrait plus avoir de brut du pays
je ne crois pas ça c'est quoi ces gens
et savoir s'il vous plaît c'est vraiment
une coupe de champagne si elle est là la
d22 n'empêche pas qu'on 3 3 3 3 3 3 3 3
regardes tu fais toujours la ja premier
je vais te dire première sur première
première chose
moi j'aime les gens que je vois tous les
dix ans et qui je peux dire tu es
toujours là
swim souvent quand j'ai rencontré pas
toujours
non c'est défendre et nous emmener à la
course et connurent des zones
qui aurait pu faire qu'on serait pas
d'allusion à faire et je suis fier de
nous comme moi je suis fier de nous être
là mais regrette qu'il ait survécu
et bien comme terminator en filateurs
recul à tort des corrections de ne rien
rater de inhabituel abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux